[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers
guten Abend ihnen
am Boden ein Trümmerhaufen das sind die
Kommentare zur Lage heute
es geht um Fußball
womit den deutschen mal zu rechnen war
zumal als Turniermannschaft und heute
Tränen fließen
Aus in der Vorrunde für die
vize-europameisterinnen die eigentlich
Weltmeisterin werden wollten in
Australien gescheitert an Südkorea
lauter fassungslose Blicke ins Leere
in und für Deutschland ist das Meer als
ein sportliches Zwischenergebnis das ist
eine Art nationale Krise und wir
sprechen dazu gleich mit dem DFB-Chef
erst das Spiel heute und die Reaktionen
um kurz nach Mitternacht australischer
Zeit kamen die DFB-Frauen am Hotel an
ein paar Germany Deutschland rufe
zauberten in das Gesicht der
Bundestrainerin ein Lächeln wenn auch
nur für einen kurzen Moment zu frisch zu
präsent war in den Köpfen aller die
Ratlosigkeit über das frühste
Ausscheiden bei einer Weltmeisterschaft
mir fehlen die Worte ich fühle mich wie
ohnmächtig
und ja kann kann ich glauben was gerade
passiert ist erstmal so ein bisschen so
real gerade Enttäuschung ist natürlich
groß kann das ganze noch nicht ganz
greifen verstehen dass wir tatsächlich
jetzt aus diesem Turnier raus sind dabei
hatte das Team von Martina fast
Tecklenburg das weit der kommen selbst
in der Hand mit einem Sieg gegen
Südkorea doch schon nach drei Minuten
machten sich erste Zweifel breit als
Deutschlands Nummer eins Merle froms den
Rückstand verhindern musste nur weitere
drei Minuten später war dann allerdings
auch sie machtlos nachdem die deutsche
Abwehr große Abstimmungsprobleme
offenbarte erzielte Südkorea ihr erstes
Turnier Tor überhaupt und das obwohl die
eigentliche Abwehrchefin Marina Hegering
ihr Turnier die Bürger
es war so eine gewisse ja Unsicherheit
zu spüren das waren wieder viele Bälle
Weg es waren wieder viele viele Personen
genau wir hatten viele einfache
ballverluster als Folge wurde
Deutschland erst kurz vor der Pause so
richtig zwingend die Flanke von Svenja
Huth vollendete die Kapitänin Alexandra
Popp ein Hoffnungsschimmer doch diese
Klarheit ließ das Team ansonsten wie
schon bei der Pleite gegen Kolumbien
erneut viel zu oft vermissen wir haben
heute
nicht in unser Spiel reingefunden mit
der entsprechenden Präzision um dann
auch ein Gegner der so verteidigt
wirklich zu was zu zwingen wieder war
der Wille da doch wieder fehlte die
Leichtigkeit vom letztjährigen EM-Erfolg
vor allem aber eine funktionierende
Spielidee so kamen sie den Zielen der
zweiten Halbzeit nie näher als bei
diesem Lattentreffer als Titel Kandidat
gestartet war der Druck doch scheinbar
zu groß das eins zu eins besiegelte das
aus und den nächsten Rückschlag für den
deutschen Fußball ich glaube wir haben
auch eine große Chance verpasst so
insgesamt für die neuen Generationen
Vorbilder zu schaffen auch durch diesen
Erfolg über dem Turnier der ist jetzt
leider nicht da eine umfassende
Aufarbeitung kündigten die Beteiligten
an
Rücktritte sind nicht ausgeschlossen
selbst die Bundestrainerin ließ ihre
Zukunft offen an diesem völlig
misslungenen Abend
nie war der deutsche Fußball in toto so
Scheintod wie aktuell schreibt eine
Zeitung heute das
frauen-nationalteam sollte eine Serie
der sportlichen Peinlichkeiten beenden
und die Fußballbegeisterung neu
entfachen in einem Land das kommendes
Jahr
EM-Gastgeber ist und jetzt Roman leskova
kaum zu glauben Deutschland ist raus
lange Gesichter in Dortmunder
Fußballmuseum oder in Berliner
Biergarten groß und klein war gekommen
angesteckt von der Erwachsenen Euphorie
rund um den deutschen Frauenfußball und
dann das
sie dachten dass sie gewinnen werden
aber haben sie halt nicht und da jetzt
seid schon sehr enttäuschen ist schade
aber was will man machen ich dachte ich
sitze noch hier und schau das
Viertelfinale das Halbfinale und
vielleicht auch das Finale und das ist
jetzt nicht geklappt hat ist sehr
enttäuschend wie sehr die Stimmung im
Aufwind war zeigt sich vor Spielbeginn
noch vor der Eröffnung des Biergartens
stehen die ersten vor der Tür
Reservierungen für Tische waren schon
Tage vorher nicht mehr möglich trotz
schlechter Wetteraussichten das erste WM
Vorrunden aus der Frauen hielten zu
diesem Zeitpunkt wohl alle hier für
ausgeschlossen
also die Einstellung der Mädels auf
jeden Fall richtig cool und die sind gut
gelaunt die werden das Rocken glaube ich
ich finde die Frauen sind schon ein
bisschen kerniger ne doch was folgt ist
die große Ernüchterung Enttäuschung nach
dem Führungstreffer der südkoreanerinnen
sowohl in Berlin als auch im Dortmunder
Fußballmuseum der Jubel über den
Ausgleich kurz vor der Halbzeit wird nur
kurz der zweite Abschnitt wird zur
Zitterpartie und Berlin zwischenzeitlich
vom Regen eingeholt manche Fan sieht nun
auch düstere Wolken am deutschen
Fußballhimmel bei den Männern wie bei
den Frauen wir kriegen nicht eine eigene
Spielidee auf dem Platz ähm es fehlt
irgendwie an der Überzeugung dass man
mit dem eigenen Spiel in das Spiel geht
das Spiel durchzieht und das Spiel
gewinnt zumindest häufen sich die
Misserfolge 2018 WM Vorrunden aus der
Männer in Russland vergangenes Jahr
wiederholt sich das Debakel in Katar und
in diesem juni scheiden die U21 Jungs
bei der EM in der Vorrunde aus
im Biergarten sind auch Spielerinnen in
einer Berliner Frauenfußballmannschaft
dabei sie sehen durchaus Probleme in der
Nachwuchsausbildung
ich denke Schluss kann sein dass
vielleicht zu viel wert schon
mittlerweile irgendwie auf Taktiken
gelegt werden also ich finde es wird zu
früh auch in der Jugend gleich so
irgendwie ja so Nachwuchstalente gesucht
und dann gleich in die
Nachwuchsleistungszentren und gar nicht
mehr so das Spielen auf dem Bolzplatz
viel Gesprächsstoff also für die
kommenden Wochen zurück bleiben erstmal
enttäuschte Fußballfans
Neuendorf ist der Präsident des
Deutschen Fußball-Bundes Herr Neuendorf
guten Abend
sie wollten ja eigentlich zur KO-Phase
dann pünktlich selbst in Australien mit
dabei sein haben Sie die Flüge jetzt
storniert
ja das ist so wir mussten kurzfristig
umplanen ich saß in der Tat aufgepackten
Koffern wir waren fest davon ausgegangen
dass wir die erreichen und das
Achtelfinale das ist jetzt leider nicht
so das ist sehr enttäuschend und ganz
bitter und es ist ehrlich gesagt auch
nicht unser Anspruch die Bundestrainerin
sagt heute das Ergebnis müssen wir uns
dem Ergebnis müssen wir uns stellen und
das in erster Linie in meiner Person
wird der DFB mit Martina Forst
Tecklenburg weitermachen
ich habe mit der Bundestrainerin
natürlich unmittelbar nach dem Spiel
schon telefoniert und wir waren uns
einig so kurz nach dem Spiel das ist
jetzt die ersten wirklichen Schlüssel zu
ziehen das ist glaube ich sehr voreilig
und das sind sehr viele Emotionen jetzt
gerade im Spiel auch bei der Mannschaft
auch hier beim DFB im Verband die
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter alle
sehr enttäuscht wir haben uns auf jeden
Fall verabredet nach ihrer Rückkehr dass
wir uns treffen aber ich kann genauso
klar sagen wir haben den Vertrag mit ihr
erst vor wenigen Monaten verlängert nach
dieser überaus erfolgreichen
Europameisterschaft im vergangenen Jahr
und haben mir das Vertrauen
ausgesprochen dass sie nach wie vor auch
genießt
dass sie nach wie vor auch genießt sagen
sie trotzdem müssen wir heute Abend auch
darüber reden was ich jetzt ändern soll
es gab ja im Frauenfußball sie haben es
gerade kurz angesprochen ein gewaltigen
Boom es gab einen historisches Interesse
gerade zu beflügelt eben von dieser
Nationalelf und ihrem Auftritt letztes
Jahr und jetzt ist natürlich die Frage
wie viel Schaden richtet denn dieser
bittere Tag heute an
ja ich glaube ich wäre nicht so
pessimistisch das eine ist das
Abschneiden der Nationalmannschaft das
ist sehr traurig wie gesagt und sehr
enttäuschend für uns alle auch nicht
unser Anspruch ich habe es gesagt aber
auf der anderen Seite haben wir ja eine
Entwicklung gesehen die glaube ich auch
sich fortsetzen wird wir haben deutlich
mehr Zuschauer und Zuschauerinnen gehabt
bei den Bundesligaspielen wir haben
pokalspieler und ausverkauftes
Pokalfinale gesehen in Köln wir haben
viele junge Frauen und Mädchen die in
die Vereine kommen und dort Fußball
spielen möchten all das hat die
Europameisterschaft im vergangenen Jahr
ausgelöst wir haben einen ganz tolles
Konzepte hier beim DFB was wir
vorantreiben Richtung Frauenfußball es
ist einer meiner Schwerpunkte auch
diesen Bereich voranzubringen und ich
glaube das sind wir um guten Weg und ich
glaube nicht das ist ein Dämpfer den wir
jetzt bekommen aber ich glaube generell
lässt sich diese Entwicklung auch nicht
mehr aufhalten auch Perspektive haben
wir Ziele wir wollen die Frauenfußball
Weltmeisterschaft ja nach Deutschland
holen 2027 das sind ja auch Perspektiven
auf die man sich stützen kann Dämpfer
sagen sehr Neudorf jetzt muss man
vielleicht nochmal auf das große
Gesamtbild auch im Moment gucken der
größte nationale Sportverband der Welt
hat eine Pleite nach der anderen zu
verkraften
wm-vorrunden aus scheint jetzt irgendwie
zur Regel zu werden wenn man sich die
Kommentare heute anguckt einer schreibt
ein Trümmerhaufen was werden sie denn
jetzt ganz konkret anders machen und
zwar generell im Fußball
also es ist immer ein bisschen sehr viel
schwarz-weiß auch da drin ich darf
einfach auch erinnern dass wir auch
durchaus Erfolge hatten jetzt in der
letzten Zeit das wird schnell vergessen
wir hatten gerade in der
Europameisterschaft der U19 Frauen da
sind wir im Finale erst gescheitert im
Elfmeterschießen wir haben gerade in der
U17 Europameisterschaft der Männer
gewonnen wir waren letztes Jahr
Europameister bei den Frauen in der U17
also wir haben im Nachwuchsbereich
sicherlich auch Erfolge in der Tat ist
es so bei den a-nationalmannschaften in
der U21 haben wir jetzt Misserfolge zu
verzeichnen gehabt und ja wir sind wie
Sie wissen mit Rudi Völler was die
anderen Nationalmannschaft der Männer
betrifft
sehr engagiert das zu drehen auch im
September mit zwei weiteren Spielen die
wir haben gegen Japan und gegen
Frankreich das wird alles sorgfältig
vorbereitet bei der Mannschaft und bei
den Frauen werden wir uns jetzt zusammen
umsetzen wie gesagt und gucken welche
Schlüsse ziehen wir da raus wenige
Stunden noch so ein Abpfiff ist das
sicherlich schwer zu sagen wenn ich sie
kurz unterbrechen darf es gibt ja ein
großes Ereignis das bevorsteht in
Deutschland so ein WM Ausscheiden wie
heute das ist das wissen Sie ganz genau
und vielleicht am allerbesten das ist ja
mehr als nur also ein sportliche
Nachricht für Deutschland nächstes Jahr
ist EM im eigenen Land wie wollen Sie
denn da jetzt noch nach all dem was sie
auch gerade selbst gesagt haben diese
unerlässliche Vorfreude bei den Menschen
schaffen
ich glaube diese Vorfreude die wird ganz
sicherlich kommen wir werden
eigentlich
durch die sportliche Leistung der
Nationalmannschaften
ich habe immer gesagt der sportliche
Erfolg steht über allem das ist völlig
richtig was sie sagen wir brauchen auch
Erfolgserlebnisse wir brauchen Sieger
das ist sicher richtig aber
grundsätzlich dass die Menschen sich
freuen auf dieser Europameisterschaft
das kann man an verschiedenen Dingen
ablesen wir haben unglaublich viele in
den Host cities da wo die
Europameisterschaft ausgetragen werden
die als volontier sich melden freiwillig
da sind enorme zahlen wir werden das
Erleben am 3 oktober beginnt der
Vorverkauf für die
Fußball-Europameisterschaft ich bin ganz
sicher dass die Tickets sehr schnell
vergriffen sein werden aber ich gebe
Ihnen natürlich recht wichtig ist auch
dass wir auf dem Platz jetzt die
entsprechende Leistung bringen und nicht
nur danach gucken okay was haben wir für
Ereignisse rund um diese EM die Freude
auslösen können sondern dass wir auch
den sportlichen Erfolg brauchen das ist
unbestritten sagt Bernd Neuendorf der
Präsident des Deutschen Fußball- vielen
Dank
vielen Dank und das Gespräch haben wir
aus Termin gründen um 19 Uhr
aufgezeichnet unser nächstes Thema er
sei der erste Präsident der USA der
einen Putsch verursacht hat das ist im
Kern der Vorwurf in der neuesten Anklage
gegen Donald J Trump the United States
of America gegen ihren 45 Präsidenten
wenn wir nicht nach all den trump-jahren
so abgestumpft wären man würde es kaum
glauben was da alles drin steht und man
könnte es beinahe also eine Art
Vergangenheitsbewältigung abtun ohne
große Relevanz für die Zukunft wenn ja
wenn Donald trade Trump nicht gute
Chancen hätte wieder ins Weiße Haus
zurückzukehren derselbe Donald Trump der
in diesem Minuten vor Gericht erscheinen
muss
eigentlich hat Donald Trump für seine
Rückkehr nach Washington andere Pläne
als möglicher Wahlsieger 2024 nun muss
er kommen um sich formal verhaften zu
lassen ein Ex-Präsident angeklagt für
den Versuch die rechtmäßige Ordnung
seines Landes umzustürzen im
Gerichtsgebäude sind die
Sicherheitsmaßnahmen massiv verstärkt
davor versammeln sich Gegner und
Befürworter Trumps der warnte heute vor
Gewalt als er in Untersuchungshaft müsse
darüber entscheidet die Haftrichterin
vorher muss der Angeklagte drinnen seine
Fingerabdrücke abgeben die Richterin die
später das eigentliche Verfahren
übernimmt wurde zufällig per Los
bestimmt aus mehr als 20 Bundesrichter
der 61-Jährigen Tanja tschadkin werfen
Trumps Unterstützer schon jetzt
Parteilichkeit vor weil sie 2014 von
Präsident Obama nominiert wurde dabei
hatte der Senat sie damals mit 95 zu 0
Stimmen bestätigt nach einem
überzeugenden Auftritt die Idee der
ideale Richter so sehe ich das ist
aufgeschlossen fair und gut vorbereitet
über Parteilichkeit ist das Grundprinzip
verhandelte viele Anklagen gegen
Aufständische vom 6 Januar verhängte oft
höhere Strafen als die Staatsanwälte
gefordert hatten einem Angeklagten sagte
sie er sei nicht aus Liebe für sein Land
zum Capitol gezogen sondern für einen
Mann
als der Untersuchungsausschuss des
Kongresses von Donald Trump Unterlagen
aus dem Weißen Haus verlangte wie sie
Trumps Einspruch mit den Worten zurück
Präsidenten sind keine Königin
auch deshalb fordern Trumps Anwälte die
Verlegung des Prozesses nach West
Virginia nur dort habe ihr Mandant eine
Chance auf Richter und Geschworene die
ihre Verteidigungslinie fair beurteilen
alles was er tat diente der
Wahrheitsfindung durch Klagen
Nachzählungen und die Bitte an
Vizepräsident Pants die Auszählung zu
pausieren
das bestreitet Mike Pants Trump habe von
ihm nicht verlangt die Auszählung im
Capitol zu pausieren sondern sie
komplett für ungültig zu erklären
diese spinnerten Anwälte erzählten ihm
was seine juckenden Ohren hören wollten
wer jemanden bittet sich über die
Verfassung zu stellen sollte niemals
wieder Präsident sein
aber genau das plant Donald Trump und
hofft dass jeder Anklage und jeder
Prozess ihm dabei helfen
ein Kandidat der hofft dass Prozesse
gegen ihn ihm helfen auch darüber werden
wir jetzt reden mit Elma teven immer
guten Abend aber erstmal ganz aktuell
was werden wir denn jetzt heute Abend
erleben in Sichtweite zum Kapitol vor
Gericht in Washington DC
also Donald Trump ist jetzt erstmal
offiziell verhaftet der hat vor wenigen
Minuten den Gerichtssaal betreten indem
keine Kameras zugelassen sind aber wir
wissen dass er den Sonderermittler Jack
Smith mit keinem Blick gewürdigt hat das
ist jetzt ein recht schnörkloses
Verfahren was da abläuft das heißt die
Anklageschrift wird den Teilen verlesen
er muss auf schuldig oder nicht schuldig
plädieren und die Richterin
Haftrichterin muss dann entscheiden ob
er ihn Untersuchungshaft kommt damit
rechnet ja eigentlich niemand weil keine
Fluchtgefahr besteht und Donald Trump
hat geplant dass er gleich auf dem
Rückweg am Flughafen hier in Washington
dann auch schon wieder eine
Pressekonferenz gibt jetzt sagen manche
immer Watergate selbst Watergate
verblasse gegen dieses Verfahren kann
man schon sagen wie der Prozess ablaufen
wird vor allem zeitlich
ja in den nächsten Tagen wird dann die
eigentliche Richterin Tanja tscherkin
übernehmen und die wird entscheiden wie
das weitere Verfahren abläuft wir
rechnen damit dass es noch in diesem
Jahr wahrscheinlich im Dezember zur
Auswahl der Jury also der Geschworenen
kommt es ist ja ein Geschworenen Gericht
das über die Zukunft von Donald Trump
entscheidet und dass wir dann nächstes
Jahr tatsächlich den Prozessbeginn haben
werden im laufenden Wahlkampf aber
Donald Trumps anwaltski hat schon
angekündigt dass es versuchen wird
dieses Verfahren zu behindern in dem
beispielsweise ein anderer Gerichtsort
beantragt wird also wir können noch
nicht Bestimmtheit sagen ob in diesem
Jahr noch dieser Prozess beginnt es ist
ja aus der Entfernung hier aus
Deutschland schwer fassbar diese
diversen Verfahren mittlerweile Schein
Trumps Beliebtheit keinen Abbruch zu tun
im Gegenteil offensichtlich warum gibt
es denn immer mehr Menschen die vor die
Wahl gestellt Trump oder die Demokratie
dann offenbar lieber Trump wählen
ich glaube das hat mit Akzeptanz durch
penetrans zu tun Don Trump lässt keine
Gelegenheit aus zu behaupten dass man
hier im Grunde um einen politisch
unliebsamen Gegner ausschalten will und
dass das gesamte Justizminister der
System der Amerika der USA dafür
gebraucht wird weil der Sonderermittler
eben vom Justizministerium bestimmt
wurde das ja zur Regierung von Joe Biden
gehört die Wahrheit ist aber dass sie am
Ende ja Geschworene über die Anlage
entschieden haben und nicht der
Sonderermittler alleine und ich glaube
es gelingt aber Donald Trump eben zu
resonieren mit dem was er sagt bei den
Menschen weil es Zweifel gibt am
Justizsystem in dem Land das hat
vielleicht auch ein Stück weit damit zu
tun dass die Bundesrichter am Obersten
Gerichtshof hier eben auch als
politischen Gründen nach einer
politischen Ausrichtung bestimmt werden
und das beispielsweise in einigen
Bundesstaaten sogar oberste Richter in
diesem Bundesstaaten gewählt werden das
heißt Demokraten und Republikaner treten
gegeneinander an in eine schmutzigen
wahlkampfschlacht und sollen dann am Tag
wenn sie dann eingefroren sind als
Richter auf einmal unabhängig Recht
sprechen also es gibt eben diese Zweifel
und das nutzt Donald Trump aus ganz kurz
noch einmal einen Präsidenten wählen der
im Gefängnis sitzt wäre auch das denkbar
klingt verrückt aber wäre denkbar
tatsächlich müsste in so einem Fall das
Oberste Bundesgericht hier in Washington
entscheiden ob die Ausübung des Amtes
sie Verpflichtung dazu wichtiger ist als
die Verbüßung der Haftstrafe und das
Oberste Bundesgericht das wissen wir ja
ist ja teilweise mit Trump nominiertem
besetzt worden also das ist ein ein
Urteil mit ungewissem Ausgang es ist
also nicht ausgeschlossen wenn er
gewählt würde wenn der Kandidat aus
seiner Partei ist dass er dann am Ende
auch Präsident werden könnte selbst wenn
ja im Gefängnisse
immer vielen Dank für diese Analyse live
aus Washington
so und Hanna hat hier weitere
Nachrichten im Blick
bundesinnenministerin
Verschiebungen
er leistungsentwurf vorgelegt und dieser
stößt auf einen geteiltes Echo der
Vorschlag sieht unter anderem vor den
Ausreise Gewahrsam von 10 auf 28 Tage zu
verlängern das soll den Behörden mehr
Zeit geben die Abschiebungen
vorzubereiten aus den Reihen der Grünen
kommt dazu Kritik von der FDP hingegen
Zuspruch die deutsche Polizei
Gewerkschaft bezeichnete den Entwurf als
Mogelpackung und forderte stattdessen
wirksame Kontrollen an den Grenzen
der vor rund einer Woche in Brand
geratene Frachter free mental Highway
ist erfolgreich ins niederländische
Eemshaven nahe der deutschen Grenze
gebracht worden damit gilt eine
verheerende Umweltkatastrophe vorerst
als abgewendet
schleppschiffe zogen den unter anderem
mit E-Autos beladenen Frachter rund 64
km in den Hafen der Stadt das Schiff war
mehrere Tage lang brennend auf der
Nordsee getrieben die Brandursache ist
weiterhin unklar
die Bundesanwaltschaft hat in Bremen
einen Syrer festnehmen lassen den
Kriegsverbrechen und Verbrechen gegen
die Menschlichkeit vorgeworfen werden
der Beschuldigte soll zwischen 2012 und
2015 Anführer einer Miliz des syrischen
Regimes in Damaskus gewesen sein die
Bundesanwaltschaft wirft ihm unter
anderem Folter und Versklavung vor der
Mann sitzt in Untersuchungshaft
nach dem Militärputsch in Niger hat die
Bundeswehr rund 30 Personen aus dem Land
ausgeflogen ob es sich dabei um
Zivilisten oder Angehörige der
Bundeswehr handelt ist bisher nicht
bekannt anlässlich des
Unabhängigkeitstages gingen in der
Hauptstadt mehr tausende Unterstützer
des Militärs auf die Straße sie
kritisierten dabei auch den Einfluss der
ehemaligen Kolonialmacht Frankreich
vergangene Woche hatte sich das niedrige
Militär an die Macht geputzt
erst war es zu trocken jetzt gucken
Deutschlands Landwirte gehen Himmel und
hoffen dass der Regen mal aufhört damit
sie endlich ernten können bei Weizen und
Roggen ist erst ein knappes Fünftel
eingefahren sagt der Bauernverband heute
und warnt wenn das so weitergeht gibt es
große Probleme überhaupt war 2023 für
die Landwirte ein nervenaufreibendes
Jahr und es ist nicht vorbei aus
Niedersachsen jetzt Oliver dolker
Regenpause in Niedersachsen Landwirt
Karl Friedrich Meyer bewirtschaftet seit
40 Jahren seine Felder bei Hameln doch
kann er seine eigentlich gute Ernte
derzeit nicht einfachen zu feucht die
halbe um sie abzuschneiden zu matschig
die Böden für die schweren Maschinen
das Getreide war durch die Hitze sehr
schnell abgereift und wir haben seit
Mitte Juli das Problem dass der Regen
doch nachhaltiger worden ist und dadurch
können wir nicht ernten und das ist
ärgerlich weil das Getreide jetzt
erntereif ist und nicht besser wird
sondern durch den Regen an Qualität
verliert zu nass das Problem der Ost-
und norddeutschen Landwirte in diesem
Jahr die Jahre zuvor weist dagegen eher
zu trocken die Zunahme von
Extremwetterlagen auch hierzulande
statistisch belegt keine guten
Aussichten für die Landwirte eigentlich
ist die Anpassung an veränderte
Standortbedingungen also ähm
Bodenqualität Niederschlag und so weiter
klassisches landwirtschaftliches
Handwerk und das kann man tun über
Sortenwahl über Bodenbearbeitung über
die Art und Weise wie ich die Bestände
führe damit stoßen wir aber jetzt in der
neuen verschärften Gangart des
Klimawandels an Grenzen bisher deckt
Deutschland sein getreidebedarf zum
allergrößten Teil aus dem eigenen Anbau
der fortschreitende Klimawandel könnte
das absehbar verändern
zu tun gefragt unter anderem der
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister auch in 20
Jahren in 30 und 50 Jahren wir unsere
Kinder und Kindeskinder darauf
angewiesen sind brauchen wir sichere
ernten das geht nur wenn wir das Thema
Ernährungssicherung Klimaschutz
Biodiversität nicht als Gegensatz
betrachten wie können wir die Forschung
so weiterentwickeln dass wir Klima
resilientere Pflanzen haben Pilz
resilientere Pflanzen wenn zum Beispiel
so starke Regen ist wie jetzt
Bundesforschungsanstalt Julius
kühninstitut Braunschweig mit dem
sogenannten reynout Shelter nichts
anderes als ein bewegliches Dach
simuliert Lorenz Kottmann Trockenheit
und Erwärmung also Extremwetter sie der
Forschung Pflanzen zu züchten den
extreme Bedingungen weniger ausmachen
man kann nicht eine Empfehlung für jeden
Landwirt rausgeben sondern ist jeder
Landwirt muss so seine eigene Strategie
fahren können ähm am besten würde ich
empfehlen zu diversifizieren also
verschiedene
Arten oder vier verschiedene Sorten
anzubauen die dann eben jeweils speziell
für eine
Umweltbedingung gut geeignet sind Carl
Friedrich Meyer hat die Hoffnung noch
nicht aufgegeben am Ende doch noch eine
ganz manierliche Ernte einzufahren
dieser Sommer ist ja eigentlich typisch
niedersächsisch kann man sagen wie wir
es in vergangenen Jahren auch erlebt
haben aber wir haben immer Perioden
gehabt wo wir trocken ernten können und
darauf hoffen wir auch jetzt in der
August hat ja erst angefangen trotzdem
der Klimawandel macht auch einen Wandel
in der Landwirtschaft nötig jetzt kommt
es darauf an die richtigen Weichen zu
stellen
und jetzt hier bei uns noch mal du
Hannah in der EU wird aktuell über ein
mögliches Verbot der sogenannten
ewigkeits-chemikalien diskutiert dagegen
laufen jetzt Industrieverbände Sturm sie
sagen dies würde die Energie und die
mobilitätswende so gut wie unmöglich
machen und bekommen dabei Unterstützung
von
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Harbeck fragen
wir nach bei Stefanie Barrett in
Frankfurt warum sind diese Chemikalien
für den Umbau zu Klimaneutralität so
wichtig ja weil die chemikaliengruppe
eben eine zentrale Rolle für
Technologien der Zukunft spielt kein
Windrad kein E-Auto kein Energiespeicher
elektrolyseure Wärmepumpen all diese
Schlüsseltechnologien kommen ohne die
Poly und per Flur Substanzen kurz passen
nicht aus wir lassen sie sich auch nicht
einfach ersetzen deshalb drängen
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Harbeck und
auch Industrieverbände auf einen
differenzierteren Regelungsrahmen in der
EU vor allem da wo der Einsatz dieser
Stoffe in geschlossenen Kreislaufsystem
erfolgt und warum überlegt die EU die
sich chemikaliengruppe überhaupt zu
verbieten ja sie gelten einfach der
europäischen chemikalien-agentur zur
Folge als mittel bis hoch giftig und
beeinträchtigen das menschliche
Immunsystem bzw stehen unter Verdacht
krebserregend zu sein weil die
sogenannten PVS Wasser Fett und
schmutzabweisend wirken stecken sie eben
auch in vielen Alltagsgegenständen wie
anoraks-gruppe zu verbieten oder sogar
zu ersetzen Ende September soll die
Beratung über ein mögliches Verbot
abgeschlossen sein die Entscheidung
trifft dann die EU-Kommission mit den
europäischen Mitgliedstaaten
vielen Dank Stefanie für diese
Einordnungen
während der corona-krise war die
Lufthansa massiv ins Straucheln geraten
doch jetzt erwartet die Airline eines
der besten Jahre ihrer Geschichte die
Lufthansa rechnet für 2023 mit einem
Gewinn von mindestens 2,6 Milliarden
Euro allein im zweiten Quartal verdiente
die Airline dreimal so viel wie im
Vorjahreszeitraum Grund sind die
ungebrochene Reiselust aber auch die
gestiegenen Ticketpreise
Papst franziskus hat anlässlich des
Weltjugendtags in Lissabon am Abend vor
tausenden jungen Menschen über die
Gefahren von sozialen Medien gesprochen
er warnte davor sich von den Netzwerken
illusionieren zu lassen bei einer
Zeremonie in der portugiesischen
Hauptstadt hießen hunderttausende
Anhänger franziskus willkommen der
Weltjugendtag gilt als größte
katholische Veranstaltung der Welt bis
zu 600.000 junge Gläubige werden dazu
erwartet
so was jetzt jetzt sollten Sie dran
bleiben wenn die Kollegin Sarah Tacke am
Puls des Landes ist wir kennen das diese
verstörenden Handyvideos die ebenso
sinnlose wie brutale Jugendgewalt zeigen
mitten in Deutschland immer wieder Thema
auch in den Nachrichten und wir haben
diese Fragen woher kommt das wer sind
die Täter und vor allem wie bekommen wir
das in den Griff Sarah wollte echte
Antworten und hat dabei mit denen
gesprochen über die so viel gesprochen
wird wir schauen uns das auf jeden Fall
an jetzt gleich nach uns und gegen 0 25
gibt's dann unser heute journal Update
mit Christopher Wehrmann tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend heute Nacht lässt der Regen
erst mal nach und die Temperaturen
sinken auf 16 bis 10 Grad dabei wird es
auf der Schwäbischen Alb und dem
Schwarzwald wie auch westlich des Rheins
am kühlsten die Höchsttemperaturen
morgen liegen zwischen 18 Grad am
Alpenrand und maximal 24 Grad in der
Lausitz der Tag beginnt erstmal
freundlich nordöstlich der Elbe wechseln
Sonne und Wolken miteinander ab sonst
gibt's schon erste Regenschauer und die
weiten sich am Nachmittag weiter aus und
dann sind auch wieder Gewitter dabei am
alten Rand selbst ergiebiger Dauerregen
ein zwischen dem Alge und dem
Berchtesgadener Land können innerhalb
von 24 Stunden bis Samstag früh 30 bis
50 in Stau lagen sogar 70 Liter Regen
pro Quadratmeter fallen und es geht
wechselhaft weiter das liegt an diesem
Tiefe über der Adria das peilt nämlich
über das Wochenende die Ostsee an und
gleichzeitig kommt auch von Westen ein
Tief zu uns das bedeutet auch Schnee in
den Alpen und dieses Tief über der
Ostsee das schaufelt warme Luft weit
nach Norden und so wird es am Wochenende
in Finnland zum Teil sogar wärmer sein
als bei uns in Mitteleuropa bei uns in
Deutschland liegen die Temperaturen zum
Teil nämlich nur bei 14 bis 20 Grad am
Montag dazu gibt es hin und wieder etwas
Sonnenschein aber meist ist es doch
wechselhaft und erst Mitte der nächsten
Woche wird es deutlich wärmer wie sie
hier im Trend für Karlsruhe sehen können
dann peilen wir mit Sonnenschein sogar
fast die 30 Grad Marke an guten Abend